>> Laura: HOUSE OVERSIGHT
SUBCOMMITTEE HELD AN EMERGENCY
HEARING THIS AFTERNOON TITLED "A
CARAVAN OF ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS, A
TEST OF U.S. BORDERS."
WHY WAS THAT NECESSARY?
BECAUSE THERE ARE NEW REPORTS IN
MS FEATURING MEMBERS ARE POSING
AS MINORS TRAVELING WITH THE
MIGRANT CARAVAN.
LOVELY.
AS IF THAT WEREN'T ENOUGH, THIS
WEEK IN THE JACKSONVILLE,
FLORIDA, AREA, A TWICE DEPORTED
ILLEGAL IMMIGRANT FROM
EL SALVADOR WAS CHARGED WITH
MANSLAUGHTER OVER THE 2016 DEATH
OF THE OFFICER TRYING TO TRACK
HIM DOWN.
DEPUTY ERIC OLIVER WAS A NAVY
VETERAN AND DESCRIBED AS A HERO
IN HIS COMMUNITY.
HE WAS 32 YEARS OLD, AND HIS
DAUGHTER WAS SIX WHEN HE DIED.
JOINING ME NOW IS REPUBLICAN
CONGRESSMAN RON DeSANTIS, WHO
CHAIRED TODAY'S HEARING.
HE IS ALSO RUNNING FOR GOVERNOR
OF FLORIDA.
I ENDORSED YOU SO LONG AGO IT'S
NOT EVEN FUNNY.
LET'S TALK ABOUT THE CARAVAN
CRIME AND OUR OPEN BORDERS.
HOW ARE YOU?
THIS IS WILD BECAUSE WE SEE
REPORTS OF LARGE NUMBERS OF
PEOPLE.
FORGET THE CARAVANS, CROSSING
THE BORDER ALTOGETHER AT ONE
TIME.
THEN THEY ARE TAKEN INTO CUSTODY
AND THEY ARE LIKE, WHO ARE YOU,
FOR YOU.
ONE GUY SAYS I'M BEING RECORDED
FOR MS-13 IN LOS ANGELES.
IT'S WILD.
WE NEED THIS WALL.
NOT FUNDED IN THE OMNIBUS.
WE NEED THE WALL.
>> THE CONSENSUS AMONGST MOST OF
THE WITNESSES TODAY WITH THAT
TRUMP BOARDED A CATCH AND
RELEASE TO BE DONE BUT YET THEY
ARE STILL --
>> Laura: THAT'S WHAT I'M
SAYING.
THEY ARE STILL DOING IT.
>> WHEN YOU HAVE THE MASSIVE
BORDER SEARCHES, THAT REALLY IS
A GODSEND TO THE DRUG CARTELS
AND THE AMOUNT OF FENTANYL AND
ALL THIS JUNK THAT THEY'VE BEEN
ABLE TO BRING INTO THE COUNTRY
THAT HAS CAUSED A LOT OF PEOPLE
TO LOSE THEIR LIVES.
WE HAVE TO GET THIS UNDER
CONTROL.
>> Laura: WHAT DOES IT MEAN
WITHOUT A WALL?
WE KEEP GOING BACK TO THE WALL.
ISN'T EVERYTHING?
IT'S NOT EVERYTHING BUT IT'S A
BIG DETERRENT.
>> WALTON DO NOT HAVE
PROSECUTORIAL DISCRETION.
IF A BUREAUCRAT DOESN'T WANT TO
ENFORCE THE LAW.
IF YOU WANT TO DO THE OLD OBAMA
POLICIES OR IF YOU HAVE AN
ADMINISTRATION LIKE OBAMA WHERE
THEY BASICALLY JUST GIVE UP ON
ENFORCEMENT, THEN YOU DON'T HAVE
YOUR LAWS BEING ENFORCED BUT THE
WALL IS A WALL AND THE PLACES
WHERE THEY HAVEN'T LIKE
SAN DIEGO, IT WORKS.
>> Laura: I WANT TO READ THIS
TO BE FULL SO THEY UNDERSTAND
THE NUMBERS WE ARE TALKING ABOUT
THE NUMBERS WE ARE TALKING ABOU
ABOUT.
AGENTS ASSIGNED TO THE YUMA
STATION IN ARIZONA CAME UPON A
LARGE GROUP OF 61 ILLEGAL
IMMIGRANTS WHO CROSSED THE
BORDER MONDAY AFTERNOON.
THIS IS FROM BREITBART.
NEAR THE SAN LOUISE PORT OF
ENTRY.
THE ILLEGAL BORDER CROSSERS
CONSISTED OF A SINGLE MEXICAN
NATIONAL AND 59 GUATEMALANS.
ONE SALVADORAN WHO CLAIMED TO BE
AN UNACCOMPANIED MINOR.
ACCORDING TO THE INFORMATION
THAT THEY RECEIVED, THEN THEY
QUESTIONED THEM, IT TURNED OUT,
THE ONCE POSTED UNACCOMPANIED
MINOR WAS AN ADULT WHO WAS AN
MS-13 RECRUIT.
FROM THE L.A. MS-13.
DO YOU KNOW, WHEN THEY COME IN,
THEN WHAT HAPPENS TO THEM?
WE HAVE GOTTEN A LOT OF THE,
GOTTEN RID OF A LOT OF THE
DETENTION CENTERS.
>> IT DEPENDS ON WHAT THEY SAY.
WE HAVE ASYLUM LAWS THAT PEOPLE
KNOW WHAT TO SAY TO CLAIM
ASYLUM.
IN ALMOST EVERY INSTANCE, IT'S
PRETTY OBVIOUS WHEN THEY ARE
COMING FROM GUATEMALA THAT THEY
ARE NOT NECESSARILY QUALIFIED.
ASYLUM IS LIKE YOU ARE BEING
PERSECUTED BECAUSE OF RACE,
RELIGION, POLITICAL OPINION.
>> Laura: YOU COULD SAY THAT
LIFE IN GUATEMALA IS
PERSECUTION.
>> THEY HAVE PROBLEMS BUT IT'S
NOT ENOUGH.
ONCE THEY DO THAT, THEY GET A
TRIAL IN TWO YEARS.
THEY GET RELEASED INTO OUR
COUNTRY.
>> Laura: WHAT YOU ARE SAYING
IS DESPITE WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION HAS SAID, CATCH
AND RELEASE IS STILL HAPPENING.
>> IT'S STILL HAPPENING AGAINST
THE WISHES OF THE ELECTED
PRESIDENT.
THAT'S THE PROBLEM.
YOU HAVE CARAVANS COMING.
THEY SHOULD BE STOPPED AT THE
BORDER.
>> Laura: THEY SHOULD NOT BE
ALLOWED TO CROSS THE BORDER.
PEOPLE WATCHING THE SHOW NOW.
WHY IS THIS HAPPENING?
IT IS INFURIATING.
THEY KNOW THEY CAN DO IT.
THE YUMA SECTOR IN ARIZONA IS
REPORTING THAT THEY ARE SEEING A
SURGE IN LARGER GROUPS.
NOW THEY ARE NOT DOING THE
TRICKLE THROUGH.
THEY ARE DOING LARGE GROUPS
MOVING ACROSS THE BORDER.
YOU USE THE WORD INVASION.
PEOPLE SAY THAT SO MEAN.
WHAT ELSE IS IT?
>> YOU HAVE HUMAN TRAFFICKING,
DRUGS.
>> Laura: THERE IS AN AD BEING
RUN ABOUT YOU THAT MAKES YOU
LOOK LIKE A COMBINATION OF
DR. JEKYLL, FRANKENSTEIN, AND A
TERRORIST.
WE CAN PLAY IT?
LET'S WATCH IT.
>> THIS IS THE SAME RON
DeSANTIS WHO VOTED.
RON DeSANTIS SAYS HE WANTS TO
HELP PRESIDENT TRUMP DRAIN THE
SWAMP BUT WHEN A REPORTER ASKED
DeSANTIS IF PRESIDENT TRUMP
WAS MENTALLY STABLE, HE REFUSED
TO ANSWER OR DEFEND THE
PRESIDENT.
THIS IS THE SAME RON DeSANTIS
WHO VOTED TO GIVE FOOD STAMPS TO
ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS.
HARDLY PART OF THE PRESIDENTS
MAKE AMERICA GREAT AGAIN AGENDA.
RON DeSANTIS.
CAN WE TRUST THE SWAMP CREATURE
TO LEAVE FLORIDA?
>> Laura: SO RIDICULOUS.
ADAM PUTNAM DID THAT ADD?
>> ONE OF HIS SUPPORTERS.
>> Laura: YOU HAVE BEEN ONE OF
THE MOST STALWART SUPPORTERS OF
THIS PRESIDENT ON ALMOST EVERY
ISSUE I CAN THINK OF.
WHICH IS WHY MONTHS AGO I
ENDORSED YOU.
HOW DO PEOPLE EVEN GET AWAY WITH
SAYING THAT?
>> THEY ARE RUNNING ON RADIO.
SOME OF THE RADIO STATION THAT
HAD TO TAKE IT OUT ALREADY
BECAUSE IT'S FALSE.
WHEN THEY SAY VOTING FOR FOOD
STAMPS, THEN THEY CITE A BILL
WHERE I VOTED AGAINST THE
FARMVILLE THAT HAD OBAMA'S
FOOD STAMP POLICIES IN THERE.
I VOTED AGAINST ALL THE FOOD
STAMPS.
CERTAINLY WOULDN'T DO IT FOR
PEOPLE HERE ILLEGALLY.
IT'S A HUNDRED PERCENT FALSE.
RADIO STATIONS OF TAKEN IT DOWN.
WORKING WITH TV STATIONS.
IT'S ABSURD.
>> Laura: HOW IS THE RACE
LOOKING IN FLORIDA?
RICK SCOTT IS MOVING ON.
>> THE FACT THAT THEY ARE
RUNNING ADS AGAINST ME.
DOGS DON'T BARK AT PARKED CARS.
I AM ON THE MOVE.
THEY SEE IT.
IT RATTLES PEOPLE.
>> Laura: I WANT YOU TO
CONTINUE TO EDUCATE THE PEOPLE
ON WHAT'S HAPPENING AT THE
BORDER BECAUSE I THINK
AMERICANS, WHEN THEY HEAR CATCH
AND RELEASE IS STILL HAPPENING,
THEY ARE INFURIATING AND
SHOCKED, AND THE PRESIDENT NEEDS